it's a lineup that'll face freddie
peralta second starts is coming off the
injured list with that sore right
shoulder that start the first start came
against the st louis cardinals he got
hit pretty good two innings
three hits four runs
for freddie peralta in that start you
can see that opponent batting average
one of the best
in the business
brewers trying to pin back-to-back
losses on the phillies phillies are two
and a half back in their division to
start play bouncing ball vogelback
scampers to it makes a play to peralta
covering the bag and there is how the
game begins
a swing adam is he finally got him a
strikeout
[Applause]
long battle with segura ends in a k and
two up and two down for peralta here's
bryce harper
mention harper 10 hits on the road trip
and harper pulls that one out toward
right bradley going back it's off the
top of the wall and it's out of the
ballpark
bryce harper with a solo home run to
give the phils a one-nothing lead his
29th home run of the year
homer hat for the second time in this
series of first-hitting home run it's
one-nothing phillies
had a strike three call 97 at the knees
second strikeout for peralta but bryce
harper gives the bills a one-nothing
lead facing kyle gibson
26 start overall he's 10-6 an era of
three and a half
long slaps one left center base hit
even the speedy jankowski couldn't run
that one down good way to start it
offensively golden wong
where the base hit to left and the
righty's pitch
swing yes he got him that's a big pitch
that was just a four seen fastball in
the inner half one out narvaez
280 solid there with 11 home runs
narvaez down the right field line that's
going to get down
in the score is wrong
and it's going to be an rbi double for
omar narvaez all tied at one they'll try
to drop a change up on omar and he would
have nothing to to do with that
bases loaded one out and it's ball four
gibson walks a run in
now the fire is really hot rbi the easy
way for vogelback it's two to one
milwaukee still won out still bases
loaded and the o2 pitch to kane
swing at the miss
that is a big strikeout second strike
out of the inning
and the one two
swag and a miss
he got it with a change up three
strikeouts in the inning
goes swinging a liner caught by escobar
this will be a nice and easy double play
just put the tag on him
that's one way to get two with one swing
of the bat who says he's not a double
play guy
kyle gibson
for peralta friday lines one over on
leaping d.d gregorius
freddy peralta put a rip on that high
fastball and picks up a base hit
there's the base hit in the right center
peralta turn and head to
third long on his way to second he is in
there
it's a keghead rally
back-to-back hits to start the second a
double by wong
here's the one-two yelich pulls one on
the ground backhanded miller coming home
and peralta's in there
oh what is brad miller thinking one
thing he's thinking is kyle gibson never
went to first base good point
good backhand pickup good throw but too
late and look at real mewtwo how far in
front of home plate he is making that
tag impossible number 11 in the at-bat
coming up two on nobody out
that he's down by two the three-two
pitch and a line drive basing it to
center field jankowski held up so he'll
stop at third and the bases are now
loaded for the phillies
three balls two strikes bases loaded
ball four that'll force it a run second
rbi for harper it's a 3-2 game
peralta ready the 1-1
line drive knocked down by ureas they go
to second for one over to first they're
not going to get him a run scores
it's a 3-3 game as gibson crosses the
plate
but jt gets an rvi is
59th strict pitch limit for peralta
because he's out and suitor's going to
come on to try to get the last out
and they called strike three inside
corner down he goes one and one bradley
tonight is over for two
fly ball center field
d.d gregorius back pedaling is under it
and makes the catch the inning is over
brockton picking up kyle gibson here's
eduardo escobar dangerous hitter
escobar sends one deep to right
and the brewers will take the lead on a
bomb by escobar
eduardo escobar
his 25th of the year
and it's the brewers leading 4-3
good day at the plate for escobar two
balls two strikes
and he got him change up
the airbender again
first strikeout for williams two up two
down here in the eighth perfect location
on that pitch down on the way
84 miles an hour
two and two
two outs
and he got him
struck him out with a change up
devon williams
strands two
preserves the lead in the eighth
one of the biggest weapons in the game
at the end of games josh hader on to try
to nail it down for the brewers in this
one run affair it's been a week
the last pitch against the giants
picked up save number 29 with a
scoreless
ninth inning that included three punch
outs he's been unscored upon in each of
his last 11 appearances
on the ground broken back urea shovels
it one throw
how about the change up from josh
slider
change up to get the ground ball into
double play is he a one
mccutcheon it's a hot one oh
it's caught and the ball game is over
and a thrilling
finish to this one partner special
season
special team shaking hands once again